morphologie langer ligne geste élégant
et précis souplesse féline
c'est patrick noah 15 ans le placer le
plus jeune de france à lomé grades les
plus élevés de 2e série
sa ressemblance avec arthur h est
frappante il est probable que le
mimétisme à jouer et il a joué d'autant
plus qu'une rencontre avec son génial
aîné l'a beaucoup marqué et en quelles
circonstances attirant contraire tu vas
retourner à yaoundé et j'ai joué avec
lui aujourd'hui nos à toutes les
promesses mais demain on a déjà si
souvent été déçu pour le moment je suis
un espoir je travaille je pense faire le
maximum pour le moment les sparrings
qu'est ce qui vous tombe dans le fait
d'arriver au tennis gagner des matchs et
une idole c'est toujours c'est pas
négligeable enfin une gagner de l'argent
gagné bien sa vie arrivé à mon but quoi
que je me suis donné c'est à dire être
moins dans les dix meilleures
noir et vos futures à ce central de
roland garros où un jour peut-être
devant des milliers de spectateurs
il gagnera la balle de match de la
finale à quoi tient le fait qu'on
devient d'un grand champion ou qu'on
reste un joueur moyen
pour beaucoup il ya d'abord à mon avis à
80 80 % l'entraînement qui est très
important surtout à ce niveau là il faut
s'entraîner tous les jours tous les
jours sans relâchement et ensuite il ya
les nerfs la tactile que tout ça mais le
plus important à mon avis l'entraînement
yannick noah quand on a un peu plus de
18 ans et que l'on est l'un des grands
espoirs du tennis français est ce que la
charge n'est pas un petit peu lourdes
dont l'achat je n'ai pas pas trop lourde
c est pas mal d'avoir quelques
responsabilités dans l'entente essayé de
faire mon possible et puis j'espère que
là le fait qu' on attend beaucoup de moi
me motivera